it's a real honor to
accelya Popovich
she is the founder and editor-in-chief
and white whorehouse correspondent for
the independent American media platform
the pavlovic today she's a political
scientist and author and an
uncompromising advocate for the freedom
of the press and that was epitomized
this past year when she made
international headlines for breaking the
White House's brief camera ban by
live-streaming one of their briefings an
audio streaming of the briefing via the
periscope app and this was a
transformative act revolutionary Act and
the White House and we changed their
policy back to allowing audio and video
back into in the briefings MS pavlovic
has a historical connection with Yale
University she was a graduate student
here I believe graduating in 2014 if I
understand correctly and while here the
Teaching Fellow she taught courses such
as the hero in the ancient Near East she
also taught up at the Divinity School of
course on American Christianity and she
assisted Professor Ian Shapiro in
creating the online version of his moral
foundations of politics course that's
currently up and running she has been a
senior instructor in the Yale Young
Global Scholars program I should mention
that that is a program that is ongoing
at Pearson has hosted in the past and
will be hosting this summer as well it's
a wonderful program and fausto was a
participant in that program as a high
school student correct you know and miss
Popovich has led a wide range of
seminars in politics law economics
International Affairs and security and
she's a native native of Serbia and as a
personal history that's May had a deep
imprint on her career path and her so
that's one of the questions I'm really
excited to ask her about today we please
join me in welcoming this but mrs.
Popovich to
thank you here thank you I'm really glad
to be here and thank you Steven for this
wonderful introduction and thank you
everyone really for taking time in your
busy schedules to come here and hear me
talk and participate in this very
important discourse we are going to have
on dress freedoms in promise America and
I also would like to say thank you to
the Pointer fellowship initiative here
during his initiative here at Yale who
is also supporting our talk today which
I find to be very meaningful in a very
difficult times for our profession and
I'm glad to be back at Yale and in a way
give back to the community the game is
so much in my intellectual I in the
acquisition of my intellectual capital I
don't like me that way I want to echo my
gratefulness to the Pointer fellowship
we have partnered with them in the past
and they are really instrumental and
bringing some remarkable guests
including our guest today to campus and
it's a real wonderful gift to this
university that they they create time
and time again as I said I want to ask
you a question about your own personal
background and I know that you grew up
under the dictatorship of Milosevic yes
and and so you had a very interesting
journey to the the point of your career
today could you talk a little if--and
and and how you came to be a journalist
and why you value this work so deeply
sure well this is also a self-reflection
for me as well and and having this
opportunity to talk to you because for
the first time also I'm here as a guest
to the environment that I hold my home
so in a way I can now look at my life
from perspective of your which while you
are doing your life journey you cannot
do so do it so well because there is no
time because you're so
all driven arrived to your destination
because if even for one moment you stop
and try to make sense of what you're
doing maybe you can get scared
especially in in the live circumstances
I was born into and that was not my
choice and it was something that was
basically given to me by my own birth by
my own nationality by my own family and
I came from the environment from
dictatorship environment in which his
climb towards freedom was a very
difficult one psychologically first and
foremost very difficult one and I like
sometimes to think that the survival
skills I have acquired for the past
let's say at least three decades more
than three decades for as hard as the
army in a Rangers training in terms of
survival skills because you're living in
the environment very you don't have to
you don't have food you don't have
electricity you can have hot running
water and for a most part of your life
this your formative years you do not get
to reflect on that in a sense to
complain because if you start
complaining then you're going to
understand how difficult that is but
that can break you and that is something
that I I believe that I acquired the
survival skill but also that very early
in my my childhood even I was aware of
the value of human freedoms and this is
what I like to say today when you're
here in America and even you know here
at the University which is really
wonderful
environment environment of freedom that
we should never take our freedoms for
granted because there were all the
generations of people who went before us
and who did this hard work that we enjoy
today and when you grow up in
environment when you do not have that
then I believe you value it even more
and I remember when I was growing up
that and that's very different from
Francis your generation here especially
here at Yale University because my
essential life question was how to make
departure while while you're growing up
in this environment you're thinking how
to make your life in this country how to
make sex how to make your life success
in this country and my formative years
were about how can I flee how can I
import how can I make my move to what
for me was a stronghold of hope and that
was America and that didn't come
overnight it was decades and decades you
know in in in the making but to go back
to your initial question which is
political question right I I was part of
a generation who was going to the
protests all the time and I remember and
I shared some notes
my personal notes with you prior to this
conversation from the political memoir
I'm working right now on I went to the
first mass protest against me launched
image that was about the freedom of
speech and against the state-controlled
media in Serbia and that was extremely
dangerous because we had the police fire
of the tear gas at the Protestants they
were feeding the crowd it was very
dangerous and I was 10 years old 10 year
old child and people asked me why why
why your mother would take you to that
process but the reason why she took me
there because this was the first massive
protest but the moment when we arrived
there no one knew that it's going to be
a mass for artists it was not supposed
to be
a massive process because there was no
enough media at that time to send back
the message to the people that this is
possible so that was the first
experience I had as a very young girl
very first experience I had there I
really learned that you need to stand up
for freedom of the press when you have
only one state control channel you need
to do something and I don't want to be
too you know really just in a way but
you're literally discolours that I want
to bring this in to this conversation
but you know in biblical terms they say
ask and you shall receive but I think
that works for the countries that are
already having the rule of law but I
think in Serbia at that time in the post
Yugoslavia it was something like us and
then fourth door open to do receive it
is like that because I felt that the
experience I was coming back then you're
driven to force the freedom in you could
not just decide one day that you want to
live free you need to fight for it and
so many journalists were fighting with
their lives and that was something that
really defined me in terms of knowing
very early what it means to make a moral
choice in politics how early on did you
know that you wanted to be a journalist
I studied journalism but I always loved
frightening but we only had the
university of political science in in
Belgrade I grew up in Belgrade the
capital of Yugoslavia and I always
wanted to be involved in in politics in
writing but the only way to do it and
that's very interesting question in fact
you could you need you needed to go to
university political science that was
run and operated by the establishment
and it was very interesting that through
my undergraduate days at the University
of Belgrade the whole journey isn't
depart department was anti-establishment
so I also had that in my experience for
very things journalists of that time for
doing resignations because they were not
agreeing with the Dean and I learned
what it means that you can resign
knowing that you're not going to have
your salary right but that you're going
to call your principals about doing the
right things so I think I I realized
that very early but I think the the
first part is that I want to it was my
mom that told me afterwards today you
learned what it means to stand for what
you believe in and that the role of a
witness in history is to write and
witness what he or she has seen so the
history cannot be forged so I I think I
was lucky that I have had in my family
my parents who never belonged to the
party of Milosevic and who were you know
okay that you're not never going to be
rich but you're going to be rich in in
our education in our spirit in our
understanding of the world and I never
had this pressure in my family that I
need to belong to her mentality and that
was very difficult because here you can
do whatever you want you can vote no
tote this is still America right but in
in former Yugoslavia at that time was
very difficult to do anything in life
without belonging to the Communist Party
mm-hmm so I want to ask one more
question then I'm going to open it up
for all of you to jump in and I want to
flash forward and ask you to engage in a
little bit of cultural analysis and
drawing on the background that you've
just described and also drawing on your
professional experience as a journalist
as a White House correspondent in
particular today yes today right so we
live in a rather tensive environment
in terms of the way that the government
and the press are interrelating gave the
example of your active resistance I
wonder if you could but I was wondering
if you could reflect a little more
broadly on the challenges that you face
as a journalist in this environment or
maybe that we all face in a certain
respect as a society and kind of lead us
through what what that aspect of your
professional life
what sort of insights you draw from that
thank you right Christopher Hitchens
white Christopher Hitchens who is really
one of my role models when he went to
interview broadcast work has quoted this
wonderful verse to him originally for
every time by Edmund London an English
point and it goes like this and why I'm
saying this you will understand it says
this is my country and it might be yet
but something came between us and the
Sun and I think that's a great opening
for what's going on today because when
we were talking about the challenges for
journalism profession it is the Donald J
Trump who is now standing between us and
Stan
and I'm using the metaphor but I think
that is the good way to start unpacking
the problems that are going on today in
in America as the journalist
specifically we work in extremely
hostile environment being working
environment there the leader of the free
world doesn't understand what it means
to be a journalist he doesn't understand
the role of journalism he doesn't
understand the First Amendment in its
foundational principles because the
founding fathers they put first amended
for a reason
in the Bill of Rights he understand he
thinks the journalism is there
to be his publicity machine and that's
not the role of the journalism because
we are the Fourth Estate we are there to
serve the public and to hold the
government accountable but he lacks that
understanding and everyone asked me why
I took a stand first as an independent
reporter as the founder of an
independent media and news outlet and
for me and draw him back with my
experience is that when a political
leader stop listening to walks properly
when he is asking us journalists to
oblige to the government that is working
against the public access to information
and in this case the access to the White
House briefing which is extremely a
special room for every freedom lover in
the world when he does that
it is the journalists who need to defend
the moral choice in politics and that
for me was a moral choice in politics
and why I believed was so empowering is
because my example is showing that you
do not need to be multi-million dollar
news corporation you can make a
difference you can't bear to voice your
opinion because I believe it is in this
country that no one should be afraid to
voice their opinions to make a political
stand peacefully of course not in terms
of you know doing something illegal but
in terms the freedoms expression if you
cannot do this here in America where can
we do it and that that is something that
I feel is the biggest challenge because
he's proclaiming the journalist the
enemy of the state and I'm not so sure
if you understand what he's doing
that's the biggest puzzle for me does he
understand
that he is not a reality star anymore
that he is the president of this country
and that with that comes enormous
responsibility because the world is
watching at you and what you're saying
and if he can make such statements what
is to stop under the dictator is in the
world from doing the same because you're
stuck caught up on this new cycle that
you'll own honesty is so exhausting so
toxic the journal is that my colleagues
in the White House briefing room
we often talk and we say we just want
one day without any news it is really
like that and there is so much that the
public doesn't know because you're not
in the trim but fearing that from every
single day dealing with toxicity on
every single level you're dealing with
incompetence and I you know the biggest
challenge I find is that he is changing
the texture of what means to live the
American dream and I will tell you why I
think that because you asked for a
cultural assessment is because American
dream was always about married yes you
can achieve whatever you want but you
need to earn it it has to come with
married and we don't they
Donald Trump is hiring people and
dealing with political decisions that's
really not the idea of the President and
meritocracy that usually people have in
mind when you think about the American
dream so that that I think it's very
interesting to look at because you have
reality stars now like Omarosa for
instance she's fired now
but you have reality stars making
political decisions that are supposed to
change lives of people without any
competence whatsoever and I'm not saying
that you can only do one thing in life
because I'm doing many things in my life
but at least you need to know something
about the subject because I believe that
politics despite all its limitations
still has the power to change lives of
the people for the better and that
should produce the highest possible good
and B that comes responsibility and he
doesn't understand that so imagine that
these topics prompt questions I'd love
to hear your thoughts questions you
might effort guests
I have a question actually goes back
under Tito this is why no there were no
mass protests in fact the motto and
you'll know what Serbia I don't know
which it's actually we are Tito or
teacher was us a figure for everybody
else if you remember that was I remember
I was a pioneer yeah okay so you know
the whole thing what was the difference
in in public or private mentality talk
about politics being a moral choice in
the Tito
versus Milosevic the difference between
a communist dictatorship and however he
describes it but how did that change
from which an era in which their Young
Pioneers and we're all trained to
believe that Tito was us and we are Tito
I was hard to believe that was a slogan
but that's what it was I've never seen
bulb lights or the square but first time
I met developer two Milazzo [ __ ] what
happened to their mighty protest and
when they're obviously weren't when I
went there the sixties and 79 ilysm
happened and they said this integration
in service la mía happened and that was
the catalyst for political violence that
erupted and during Tito's time he was
capable to keep all these communities
together under the umbrella of Yugoslav
identity but then you had nationalism
popping up and I think when you have
such a strong populism popping up in in
in my the country is disintegrating
there's lots of bad things happen and
then people I think unleash
their identities and they want to change
because they were not happy with with
with the system that I think was the
reason why the opposition happened in in
Belgrade during Milosevic and why did
they dare to protest I think maybe
because it was the right thing to do
because maybe the country maybe they
were able to look what's going on in
other countries I'm really not sure what
the answer is but I remember that in my
family that was just like an oxygen to
go to the process and people didn't want
to be exposed to propaganda anymore it
started with the media this is how it
started the first massive protest in
former Yugoslavia in Belgrade in Serbia
in March 1991 that was the process for
free press it was not the process per se
against me we didn't start as a
rebellious act against Milosevic it
started as a protest against the
national television and then it just
went from there because he sends the
tanks military tanks on the streets and
then young people like yourself today
they were this driver of the change and
you asked me a fantastic question but
I'm not too sure you know even for
myself I have an answer to that you just
dared it was not even a question whether
you should do something or not do
something you just wanted to live free
that was how I felt it how my generation
did it we didn't go to classes we went
to streets to protest and I remember
it's 8 o'clock and this is how it
started because they were giving this
propaganda on evening news at 8 p.m.
every single day people were going
opening the windows and they were taking
like pans and pots
and they were you know drumming depends
and pots in practice for the whole
duration of the evening news edition so
it didn't happen overnight it was a
gradual tenure long process that
culminated in the spectacular a bombing
of Belgrade and then finally we were
able to vote him out of the office suite
it was October 5th 2000 that no one
really knew how it's going to pan out
because they were he was making orders
for the power paramilitary units to go
on the streets and kill the protesters
so it was a gradual movement towards
freedom and democracy in the White House
briefing room and other venues you rub
shoulders with representatives if I may
call that of Fox News and other Trump
outlets do you have any sense of how
those people really feel about what's
going on are they true believers or are
they you know do we just for the money
or what's in their moist to the extent
that you know know them personally
well definitely briber
he's a believer I I would think that
they are believers
I think patronage dad know me Charlie
pronounce his name I'm like certain rich
I think he's also for you with l'amore
his family I think he's also a believer
Alex Jones his believer Fox News in my
view is if I'm free to say right now a
government propaganda channel that's how
I see it
you you you got to believe in this stuff
in a way to be able to advocate it
they are doing I would not be able to do
it but whether they're believers that
are doing it for money or maybe it's the
combination of all these incentives it's
very difficult to know motivations of of
people but I would think that you have
to believe in nonsense in order to
promote it what is the nature of your
relationship with other journalistic
colleagues is it I imagined some mix of
collegiality competitiveness how does
that play out on a day to day basis do
you people that you hang out with the
people you tend to like get into little
scuffles with you know how does that
when it came first to the White House
briefing room there was a veteran
reporter I can't say he's me but he's
very famous and he told me mr. lovak
you're now in a shark tank make a see
that find a few friends no didn't even
use the word friend you find a few
people you can trust
make the waves but only then you're sure
that your boat can make it to the other
side interesting now very clear Joe
doesn't want you to think yeah or maybe
he doesn't want me to me today if I'm
going to riving those that yeah so it is
the mix if I really want to be honest
here it's it's extremely competitive
work environment I am I'm a high
achiever but this level of
competitiveness I don't think that I
have ever experienced in my life just
being in its room is the life experience
in itself there are people who are going
to be very honest and supportive of you
but the problem is with the environment
is that every single person is competing
for what you are competing for
and then many especially among the young
people who are coming you know new
reporters they are doing this in order
to get a transfer to something better so
you have this chain professional chain
that everyone wants to climb up in order
to achieve something but for me that's
different because I already come as an
owner of my own media so I do not have
this kind of ambition so but there are
people who are gonna really be there for
you it happens I have a very nice
relationship with a few of of
correspondence and I feel I can trust
them but but what you don't know is that
we do not talk about anything inside of
that room there to go that's it we
always go outside and that was the the
some of the things they told me when I
came do not to make any comments inside
but you know I'm thinking you know if it
really didn't want to know what they
think they know it already it's
difficult to hide but I ask you to do a
cultural analysis of effectively the
administration in that situation okay if
you turn the glass the other way I mean
how do you I mean this may be difficult
because the journalistic profession is a
variegated landscape right but how do
you think journalists as an institution
are holding up their end of the bargain
are they do you feel like collectively
you and your colleagues are rising to
the occasion or do you sometimes you
come away disappointed sometimes that at
what what you observe amongst those
sharing the same task it's a great
question and I'm just trying to
Frances when it came in the situation an
example of the broadcast ban
I felt that we did not raise to the
occasion
as a group that's how I feel that Island
a little bit like on your own because I
feel we were tiptoeing around something
that we were not supposed to tiptoe
around and why is that there are many
reasons why one is you know access you
want access you don't want to be banned
from the White House
you work for a corporate media that has
so many stakeholders they are they tend
to make more conservative decisions but
at that moment I felt that we were
sliding into complacent surrender there
you're in situation where you know
you're saying okay fine no problem when
the old news America that our role was
to say no and to make us and and I and I
would like to see more solidarity in
that sense among our profession to be
less about the networks but more about
the profession because I believe that
every journalist who sat on a journey to
to write about history and be so close
at the source because we gather news
before you gather knows that that's kind
of proximity we have in the White House
press corps when you set on you're
turning like that you wanna do it for
the right reasons you you want to do it
as a service and I believe that
corporate networks are too much taking
from that away from the troll because
there is a contract their advertisers
corporations
and in my personal view I believe that
corporations do not care about the
individual voice they care about ratings
and this is why I like academia because
here you can exercise your autonomous
thinking your autonomous decision-making
you decide what topic you want to focus
on what to give your priority to so
journalism can learn a little bit more
now I believe from the university
settings because I believe it right now
in America the universities are the
freest
intellectual State intellectual space
it's fake news has come to the spotlight
it's certainly being tweeted very often
and how is this concept of fake news
changing the way journalists approach
their task has it had positive impacts
at all or is it really just an attack on
journalism from the perspective of the
president you mean or from our
perspective from your perspective well
the whole term peak news was invited by
the president and it's a punch line for
him like it as it was his punch line
you're fired
so he's now using his fake news every
single time he dislikes the news and
that is the problem so how to is this
the problem it is a problem because
someone you have a president that states
undermining the trust in the media and
he's sitting in the office of great
power
he's not a private citizen so he has
this huge responsibility and he's not
holding that responsibility so when the
leader of the free world tells you your
fake news that remind you is a problem
and it goes against the American values
as to what our political leadership
should be about and what has always been
about in the history of this nation fake
news I heard from dictators when I was
growing up when when the president hood
asking for a firing of journalists when
he would order in you know for some
journalist to be presume removed I
remember when I was watching the news
edition when the presenter would list
the names of of journalists who are now
the enemies of the state but this is all
in a broader context of fake news
because they wants you to believe that
this is all propaganda and then he's all
the time praising Fox News as this was
his own publicity machine and these
people at Fox News they do not question
anything it's just like his blind
consensus as to anything what he says so
in that sense it's it's dangerous how we
receive this as as journalists as people
who are working on this we know we know
the meaning of that we know it is a
tough question because how we can how we
can resolve this problem that is the
biggest maybe like a larger issue here
and you do this by increasing the
competency in the newsroom and the way
of riot question is framed I think it's
very most telling go to what he's doing
that he is always picking one side
against the other and then you are
having like this screaming match
basically a crossfire where all you see
and hear is the noise but there is no
substantial analysis there are no
implications there is no solution given
it is about your fake news and you're
doing a great job
am i hearing correctly that one of the
consequences of this these these
rhetorical attacks is amongst you and
your colleagues is a kind of greater
sense of burden to raise your game in
other words that that there's a tangible
effect on the pressure you feel to
somehow continually attain a quality of
product you have to you need you need to
stand up to that because this is serious
it in Y is dangerous because it became a
punchline and why is it dangerous is
because he's capable to serve these all
labels and punchlines to the nation with
dimension of entertainment and because
it's so entertaining I believe it's very
dangerous because if a political leader
is I just want to finish this because I
think it's very important because if a
political leader is serving you abuse on
a daily basis in a very open way you're
going to push back automatically right
even in life real-life situation if
bully tries to punch you in the face
you are going to try to push him back
but when someone is serving you the
views and analyses and conceptions that
he has about the news to very
entertaining packages that that is this
is when the audience is becoming more
acceptable it
you mentioned entertainment and then you
also mentioned or we've talked about
kind of the journalists feeling this
increased duty to put out good content
to to maybe
counter what you think is propaganda and
I was wondering where you think social
media played a role in that if you think
that or I don't know like as a
journalist how do you feel social media
has affected our ability to receive like
good analysis and and has it exacerbated
that entertainment value of news over
maybe I don't know the useful
information that we need in order to
make choices as citizens because when
you are supposed to say something very
smart in 140 characters now they
increase the characters but if you are
post and asked to deliver the
information to deliver deliver substance
to deliver solutions in a very you know
limited tweet then of course it's social
media is responsible when we as the
media are reacting to every tweet he
makes given at 11 p.m. then we are also
taking responsibility in contributing to
that because not everything he does is
news 13 cents that increases the
knowledge the understanding sometimes I
think that the coverage we are producing
about the president fits the Mandate of
the TMZ rather than any serious
political journalism and for me it's
even more difficult because I'm
political scientist so I I studied
politics and I have a little bit deeper
understanding of the world and Social
Sciences and how you ask a good question
and then I see the discourse you're
having and I'm not pleased with what I
see because it's not such a good quality
of this curse because we do not hear any
explanations we do not hear any
solutions and no one is telling us how
to change that and I believe the Ute is
the future and this is why my my own
platform is dedicated to helping young
people engage and be creators of the
ideas and solutions and the news instead
of being the consumer and I think that's
quite Donald approach because everyone
is treating your generation as the
generation of consumers so everyone is
trying to subscribe you for something
but I would like to see our generation
as as the leader of a change that is
going to say ok what I think matters I
have ideas that matter I want to have a
say what kind of future we are going to
create because I am I mean you you are
going to be the leader and the holder of
that future and we need to think about
the footprint for Humanity that we want
to leave because I think that's that's a
future of journalism is a future of
political leadership call it even the
new political design but we need to
start caring about world leadership
humanity solidarity you know in a good
way
in a forward-looking way progress the
way not progressing in terms of
political parties but progressing in
terms of creative progress for our
humanity that's that's for me it's a
crucial issue especially with my
experience as I lived through extremely
difficult times and I know what it means
that you have a precancerous cells
inside
that can lead you to to the limitation
of freedoms regarding just sort of the
your conception of what it means to be a
journalist and how that definition is
changing especially because like in
terms of international protection like a
journalist is just considered a civilian
I mean I guess it's narrowed in terms of
whether they're involved with the
military or not but especially with the
other question in terms of like how
social media is impacting sort of the
immediacy of journalism like how do you
think that definition of what it means
to be a journalist has changed and how
should it change with the changing times
and the journalist you need to serve the
public
journalism is probably the only place
where you can be free that you can
exercise freely your intellectual
faculty and you need to pull the truth
and ethics and I'm going to go back to
the moral choice journalist always needs
to defend the moral choice in politics
and to hold the political leaders
accountable I do not like this trend
where the IT people are now overtaking
journalism Facebook is overtaking
journalism victories are all overtaking
me journalists that in my view is a
problem I don't like it because I was
reading today student publication
security l and honestly I was impressed
how good the content is in these
publications why do we not seem there of
that in our media landscape so to go
back to your question what it means to
be journalists I understand you you want
to be a journalist or you are a
journalist so I think what it means to
be a journalist is forever do decide to
be
and if there is one you know lesson I
think I know for sure in life is that
you can become whoever you want by many
ways you can do you can do it with this
group of people or that group of people
it's up to you but you need always to
know that you what you're doing is good
for you and it speaks to you to your own
integrity to your own values so before
knowing what it means to be a journalist
I believe you need to know who you are
what it means to be you what it means
what it means to be a decent human being
well let's talk about that because I
feel we don't have that anymore in our
political system right now in our
political landscape let's do this return
to humanity and basic human decency and
morality and ethics and just do good
thing do the right thing whether you're
doing it or you are a banker or you are
a professor or you are pure person I
don't know but it needs to come from you
and I think this is why all this study
security'll directed studies grant
strategy program all these kind of
classes are also shaping you as a human
being we have a course that's being
offered this semester called what is it
psychology and the good life which has
attracted over 1,200 students so I think
I think they're voting with you on that
yeah right here rights to journalism
that we
social media from people receiving their
news from other sources from suppression
what steps do you think journalism will
have to take to survive in our formative
future if any to survive I mean what
then the same to continue to reach the
audience in a way that is effective
informative and doesn't compromise
journalistic values integrity that's a
great question I think we should not be
focused so much on the forum because
journalism right now is so much
concerned about ecology how you deliver
the news how you distribute you name use
but it has a very little to do with the
content creation and everything now
needs to be soundbite ready and even if
you invite a scholar to talk on his or
her area of expertise the media is
expecting this person to deliver
everything in already ready-made
somebody needs to be you know very
distilled on point and politics is
complex so the future of journalism has
to be about substance and has to be
about longer forms I believe I was gonna
ask you what are the news outlets or
sources that you most like to go to
outside of your own obviously in other
words where do you see that with that
vision that you're talking about whether
long a forum or the kind of the the
kinds of journalism that captures the
complexity of the issues involved where
do you what places do you think do that
well right now
perhaps c-span is the one that is
allowing the fists and panels and larger
conversations and they're filming talks
at universities
I honestly gonna see it anyway any enemy
under your channel right now okay so
that's a that's a video what about what
about written forms of media what other
specific places you go they're doing a
real that's good stuff it's good stuff
yeah I'm eclectic look I like to read
some things in Washington Post I like to
read some writers in New Yorker I like
to read the things in New York Times
basically big legacy media there's
foreign affairs
yes Pacifica writers that you whenever
you see a byline you're like yes I think
my favorite writer he's dead I am going
to interviews olsommer to name is he I
asked him another question and he said
all my role models are dead and I
thought it was funny but no one I'm
becoming this person that I can say the
same I might really real grow more it
was he who Christopher Hitchens
because he was so bold and there are
ideas about it he had idea that I
absolutely disagree with but he had this
intellectual baldness and this courage
to speak his mind and I do not see that
a lot at the level that he was capable
to to really strike this intellectual
conversation so I don't have better
answer other questions
what's the nature of the government in
Serbia today and how are they you know
people they are reacting to to Donald
Trump
you know people in Serbia and the
governments they love yeah they love
Donald Trump epithets you need to
understand that Serbia has this history
of dictatorship so they would probably
love Donald Trump and leaders like that
it is the voltage Aleksandra voltage he
is the president he was a former prime
minister and he was one of the people my
generation was fighting against so this
is why I you know I always think people
are talking right now how they are going
to vote out Donald J Trump from from his
office but that's not that easy because
you can watch someone out from the
office but what you really want to work
out are regressive political ideas so
it's not about the individual it is
about the ideas and these ideas have
some very strange way of showing up the
surfacing in the history especially with
in countries with repressive past even
if you look what's going on in Middle
East which this is Islamist movement
terrorist movements they had these
intervals when they show up and they go
basically underground and they so you
need to treat problems at it's very
source and how you do that by educating
people and inviting everyone to be an
active citizen inviting everyone to be a
critic with arguments never personal
never be personal that I think is
because you asked me before about the
colleagues in the in depression groom I
believe that even those who are very
passionate supporters of Donald Trump
and they have a certain level of respect
for me because they say you're never
personal you III talk about issues but
that's again political scientist in me
never allow yourself to be personal and
going back to Serbia I'm not optimistic
about the leadership of Serbia right now
I am NOT because it puts my generation
in a very difficult position where I'm
asking myself what was it all for what
was it all for
I don't know but this is why I don't
lean in certainly anymore
this is why I made America to be my home
because this is the country that I love
this is the country where I can make you
know my future my family and and you
know I feel like I did the hard work for
for my future children because in this
country even if you were born here you
need to remember that there was always
someone in your family line who came
here and stupid or they did the hard
work so you can live the life you're
living today and that is why I I feel so
strongly against the political project
Donald tracker is proposing for this
nation especially in the context of the
immigrant population because people come
to this country to live free that's the
bottom line
even the dreamers the family of the
dreamers this famil these families came
to this country in order to give the
future to these children and we must
forget it this is why it's kind of my
mission right now to go and talk and to
inspire all of you to be active citizens
and to write and engage and talk and
argue for the freedom because you need
to defend humanity that's how I feel my
my roommates actually an international
student from Belgrade and both my
parents came to America after being the
Tiananmen protests in Beijing also kind
of about free speech and so that's why
they're here so I was just wondering how
important you think it is to have that
kind of either immigrant voice or voice
of someone who's gone through hardship
in journalism or in the media that's
produced and how important that is as
far as how it shapes the way you look at
issues or discuss issues and what it
means for I guess the media that you
produce mm-hmm well I think it's
extremely important first survival
skills are important for any profession
you want to go into but I am well there
of the platform I have been given and I
hold responsibilities as to how I use my
platform today as an immigrant as the
woman I broke the glass ceiling for many
immigrants and that is why I feel it's
very important that I speak on their
behalf because remember I came to
America first to Yale University which
is already a great privilege and at the
time then I came to America it was
already my free choice that was not a
necessity I could live in Madrid I could
live at that time in one
I went to London School of Economics I
was already established enough that I
can make a choice as to where I want to
go in life and there I want to work in
Inlet and but I have chosen this country
and that speaks volumes about the
immigrant experience and the American
identity design in that sense I take my
role seriously and I want to help
immigrants who are just now hoping to
that maybe one day they're going to be
able to come here but they look at my
experience and they say yes I can do the
same she did it from Serbia I didn't do
it from England or from Canada or some
some cool place peaceful place at least
from Switzerland I did it from this you
know country the president is referring
to I'm not going to use the word but you
know what I mean so I may be the example
how someone from the this type of coal
country right to come to this country
and the skill uphold the values the both
of this of this society and I think
that's extremely important the tea once
you're giving the platform did you use
it for good cause I think would be
possible to give Trump credit for
writing two strategies on his
nationalism or more particularly white
nationalism and another is
authoritarianism numbers you might say
he's on the right side of history in
that there's an impulse toward
nationalism a tribal impulse that we
many maybe all of us have toward fascism
and in the modern world the most
successful economies appear to the
authoritarian if you look at
China Singapore etc these authoritarian
societies are actually outperforming
democracies so is Donald Trump on the
right side of history he's 100% on the
wrong side of the history and I am sure
that many nationalists who started many
worse and and who who triggered human
atrocities they also totally liberal
right side of the history I think the
nationalism is the concept is absolutely
outdated concept and I will tell you why
because I changed so many passwords even
in former Yugoslavia and I never left
the country
I was yoga Slav I was in Serbia and
Montenegro and then I was Serbian and I
lived in Belgrade he didn't change so
for me I believe that sometimes this
concept of national nationalism is
nothing but a fifth stamp it fits them a
fifth call me the passport it doesn't
really mean anything and that's why it
I believe American design is very
successful because it's all inclusive
and in all encompassing of all of us you
can be Greek American you can be
Spanish American because it connects to
universal values of identity anyone can
be American you can have an accident and
be in America right so I I don't like
nationalism because I I watched what was
going on in terms of the economic
argument the argument of the economy but
what's wrong with US economy and Donald
Trump made his fortune in the u.s.
within these economic climates so for
him to advocate that we should do it
like China I'm just confused
the question let me ask you to look
forward and we'll close with this
project yourself 10 years hence 20 years
hence where do you see that the pathway
forward taking you where do you want to
go because I've been very asked this
question because I'm sure you have an
answer to this because you strike me as
someone who who sets goals and brings
those goals into effect that's I think
that's that's something that marks your
life on several levels so I mean
traditionals
I believe that I'm your intuitive
innocence that sometimes I do not have a
clear goal but my intuition the green on
two takes me to that goal there I see
myself honestly I want I'm dealing with
other questions in life right now in a
sense of who I am as a human being so if
I want to project myself in twenty years
from now I just want to be at peace with
my life decisions that I travel the
right pad that's instantly it's very
important to me that I can look myself
in the mirror and know that I did not
cave in and maybe there was a pressure
for me to came in that I honor my life
journey and Who I am as a person as an
intellectual and that I always am in a
place where I act responsibly because I
feel that my life journey was he has
driven by my ambition and desire of
course but there was also I believe some
Divine Design in it if you all because
it doesn't happen so often so I believe
that I hold responsibility to all these
people I met in my life
and I've worked with and
into this community tailed universe
because it's so rare for anyone who
comes from Serbia to achieve these
intellectual heights so I want to be
always wherever I I'll be coming in the
next 20 years I want to have the sense
of knowing that I will disappoint all
these people so whether I'm going to be
in politics or whether I'm going to you
know keep expanding money on my
journalism in my media but one one one
thing I know for sure is that I'm going
to write books okay yeah oh we I want to
thank you for your accountability your
sense of accountability and
responsibility and the way that you hold
accountable all of us including our
government in the work that you do so
thank you very much for you join me
[Applause]
[Music]
you